dr artium placed one biography about the  late comic book writer stan lee and one  lenovo laptop into the clockworks on  very fine the result was that the top of  the laptop seemed to be replaced with  the original cover material of said book  and all lenovo logos on the laptop were  replaced with the word excelsior on  starting up the laptop researchers were  met with an animated humanoid on screen  who resembled stan lee the humanoid was  able to speak and respond to questions  asked of it and several questions  related to the life of stan lee were  answered accurately dr artium noted i  need to go and cry for a minute  excuse me